ce phénomène de perversion d'internet et
mondiale président américain bill
clinton en personne et c'est d'imposer
une loi sur l'utilisation de ce système
car aux états unis des sites internet
s'ouvre sur n'importe quoi exemple un
site qui met à disposition des lettres
de tueur en série est actuellement
emprisonné et qui s'expriment sans
aucune censure
washington maryse viaud sandra london
est une femme étrange cette américaine a
une passion la vie d'un serial-killer
ces tueurs en série qui font
régulièrement la une des journaux sur
eux elle a écrit deux livres mais elle a
aussi créé un site sur l'internet
plusieurs pages sur le web où elle
raconte dans les détails parfois les
plus sordides la vie et les crimes de
ses hommes
en fait elle ne fait que reprendre leurs
propres mots car les serial killers
connaissent sa passion et lui écrivent
régulièrement de prison ce sont donc
leurs lettres mot-à-mot qu'elle
reproduit sur l'internet par son
intermédiaire les plus célèbres aux
assassins américains ont trouvé une
tribune inespérée et mondial mais le
site a tellement choqué l'amérique qu'il
a été bannie par aol le plus grand
fournisseur d'accès sur l'internet
sandra london a facilement trouver un
autre fournisseur mais elles crient
aujourd'hui à la sangsue question n'est
pas ont-ils le droit de s'exprimer ou
ai-je le droit de les publier la
question est est ce que quelqu'un est
autorisé à m'arrêter
la réponse est non parce que quand vous
commencez à abandonner votre liberté de
parole
on vous l'a prend vraiment peut-on tout
dire tout écrire sur l'internet
la réponse n'est évidemment pas dans les
archives de la prestigieuse librairie du
congrès le premier amendement de la
constitution américaine garantit
simplement la liberté de parole et de
presse alors quand les responsables de
la librairie ont décidé de créer une
section avec accès à l'internet
ils ne se sont pas demandés si tel ou
tel site était indécent c'est en fait à
chaque utilisateur de faire sa propre
sélection
je crois que c'est bien le laisser
chaque personne décider tout seul de ce
qu'elle veut voir
par exemple je veux pas voir de
pornographie alors je ne demande pas
internet de montrer si jamais tomber
dessus même par accident alors moi je
crois que c'est bien comme ça steelcase
l'un des grands patrons d'america online
plus grands fournisseurs d'accès à
l'internet au monde 10 millions
d'internautes prêts chez lui chaque mois
leur abonnement lui et son entreprise se
sont battus contre le fameux 10 en six
actes cette loi voulue par clinton
prévoyait une peine de deux ans de
prison pour tout créateur de sites jugés
indécents ou choquant nous pensons que
ce sont les consommateurs eux mêmes qui
décident que tout cela est de la
responsabilité des arts vivants et non
du gouvernement
la loi proposée par clinton a finalement
été jugée inconstitutionnelle
sandra london ne peut donc continuer à
publier les lettres de ces serial killer
il y aura toujours un fournisseur pour
accepter son site
les parents honteux toujours la
possibilité de côté une partie du réseau
s'ils veulent interdire à leurs enfants
enfants